so marand costro comes on the podcast
the I said what's your favorite curse
word yeah probably I think it might be
the number one sound on TK I have one
Tik Tok video that has like
178 million views or something in the
rest like 7 million six Mill you should
have named the special probably I should
have so so this thing goes viral
obviously um and Aon does a song called
probably and he takes the audio and it's
like what we going to do tonight girl
and it goes probably Miranda's voice is
in it the whole thing wait who's suing
he's suing you no he it comes out and
then everyone's like you got you can't
let this it's also Miranda who's the
sweetest person and I'm like this girl
has worked so hard to she's the only
actress or performer you could that
hasn't you know shown her she sounds
stressed out she sounds like she needs
like a man in her life what a man who's
like Charming man who loves dinosaurs
all of a sudden looks like he's staring
to the sun I don't know my romantic
faceand I'm dying for you and Miranda to
get married then what happened we'll get
married in your backyard is where the
her stock almost killed her who's suing
who you're suing Aon so Aon so they're
like oh we need to send him like a
season because also let have it it's Aon
he got a big if anyone else wants it
they can have it especially just cuz he
got money no do you remember when he
like humped a 14-year-old girl on stage
and then he said put a song out about it
and then he well and then have you heard
the apology song that he did okay I
talked to my friends about this recently
like the it blows my mind they're like
hey man you you should probably
apologize and he's like I will I'll also
make millions of dollars doing it but by
the way he and he drags Gwen Stefani in
it to apologize the things I've done and
things that haven't occurred yet all the
things he's protecting himself in the
future when he smart this is a the
lawyer wrote this song but he also I'm
sorry for the times I left you home I
was on the road and you were alone I'm
sorry the fact that I did not know now
it gets past aggressive sorry for all
the things I did not know cuz I can't
read your mind gas he's being such a
this is okay you can tell who what the
lawyer wrote versus what he wrote he got
notes and then he's like but the
funniest part is he brings Gwen safani
in he's like he's like I was on tour
with Gwen safani she's like leave me out
of thise leave me out not deal with this
but yeah he made a song about it and
it's got like millions of like views and
streams I understand that there are some
problems yet you humped a 14-year-old on
stage how did the publisher be like oh
yeah put that out and he's like oh no
this is about a friend I'm sorry all the
things that he put you through who's
that third person and I'm sorry for the
times you didn't know what to do this is
the worst nursery rhyme I've ever read
oh and even though pops treated us like
Kinks he got a second wife and you
didn't agree it doesn't even rhyme like
that's how badly there're um get wait
can you read the part about Gwen safani
I just love how she just catches a stray
in this that is so I'm sorry for club
Zen getting shut down okay that was
personal that's one of the lines here it
got shut down because of this I'm sorry
that it took too long to see and they
were dead wrong trying to put it on me
I'm sorry that it took so long to speak
but I was on tour with Gwen
Stefani like but that's actually a good
lyric because her she has a song called
Don't Speak
oh so that's actually what that was
right I mean it's like funny to flex in
an apology I wanted to do a video a long
ass time ago was like the producer when
he was recording lonely and the producer
like are you good man it's like lonely
so Lon and the guy's like I'm Mr Lonely
like should we pause you need a hug so
we send like a cease and desist because
I'm actually here's I'm a little I that
guy he put lights he put lights up for
his country he put like G like so many
liks called
senagal um is where he's from you don't
remember this that
he this girl you have seen this girl on
stage that he brought up on stage and
like dry humped her she was 15 years old
oh my God why can't I get into anything
everything has got ad blockers how do I
get out of these ad blockers I don't
even know what to do well it's right
there see this is how he avoided jail
time that no the the jury didn't want to
go through the ad blocker I was like
that was fine he seems Inn I'm not
trying to back the fact of that I'm just
it's just to do a song that's about like
let's go it's Miranda Costco being like
probably and I'm like either pay her for
it pay us it's it's my property because
we own our podcasts like you probably
own your podcast like there's so few
things that we own and I know that he
just went oh these are girls who gives a
I'm just going to steal this property
from them and not credit them not
license is it a good song it's kind of a
Bop that's the part that's the part but
then I also was like I invite Miranda
costro this Angel kind of a b b b i you
know okay I'm charging you for that